然后第三。
关于主角的。
出现问题。
关于主角的出生问题。
主角出生问题啊，很多实操的作品中啊，大家会。
讨论一个到底是高开还是低开更好更顺的问题。
在这里我统一给大家回答一下啊，我是比较倾向于低开。
我希望我们的主角从平凡中来。
就他从平凡中来。
开场低开。
比较好做。
但是可以有血统。
可以有血统。
而且一般来说有噱徒。
在凡间，但是有血头。
明白这个意思吗？大家去回顾一下，大部分的片子是这么做的，因为这么做好做。
而且主角呢一般从平凡中来到平凡中去。
到平凡中去。
比如说。
我不是药神。
我不是药神开场。
徐峥在干嘛？
买药。
卖那个印度神油。
对吧开那种小店卖印度神油。
然后。
他在经历了一系列的大风大浪中之后。
也赚过钱，也救过人，也也有很多人跟着他，对吧？也有很多人这个这个这个指望他，然后呢又去蹲监狱。
最后出来以后。
他从监狱出来以后。
他小舅子周一为去接着他。
出狱以后，他小舅。
接了他问他。
出来了，打算干点啥呢？
接着卖巡游。
接着卖谁油。
这就是我说的，从平凡中来到平凡中去。
到平凡中去。
哎，不过有同学会问啊，那呃我不是药神，这个这个这个呃主角。
没有血统啊。
他可不是什么遗落在民间的王子，是吧？
因为他不是他是个现实题材的片子，所以他不可能当然不可能是王子这种噱统。但是大家去看我的人物看人物小传那一课里面血统包括什么？
学统除了你的出身教育背景，教育背景也算学统啊，同学们啊，教育背景也算学统。除了你的出身，你的教育背景以外，还有个东西也叫血统，叫家庭关系。
他有学头。
他有个当警察的小舅子。
而且他这个当警察小舅子就是抓卖假药。
对这件事情，这个血统对于它的主线卖假药，它不就是一个。
有相当影响力的血统吗？
你要卖假药，然后你家里有人是。
警察专抓卖假药。
这就是血统。
明白吧？
所以这里关于这个主角出身的问题。
我认为。
平房开比较好。
但是最好有血统。
最好有学徒，然后你从平凡中来的话，就让他最后回平凡中去。
回平凡中去。
加勒比海盗大家记得吧？这个我也在课上给大家讲过这个片子，加勒比海盗的结构。我们说加勒比海盗的主角是谁？
克纳对吧？奥兰多布鲁姆嘛，那那个角色他演的那个那个小男那个那个男孩叫特纳。
他是个铁匠。
平凡不平凡。
他在一个。
海边小镇做铁匠平繁吗？平凡。
有没有血统？
有啊，他是著名海盗特纳的儿子呀。
而且他这个身份隐藏了。
那个小女孩帮他隐藏了嘛，伊丽莎白和他父亲把这个特纳从海里救下来的时候，她脖子上挂着海盗的金牌。伊丽莎白把这个金牌给给密了，给藏起来了，等于隐藏了特纳的。
学徒身份。
然后让他从平凡中来。
明白吗？
啊，当然很多人有疑问问我，加勒比海盗的主角是谁？加勒比海盗的主角不要问，就是特纳。
不可能是杰克船长呀。
不可能是这个船长呀。
我们说主角的要有主动力啊，我们这个这个。
加勒比海盗的故事是什么来着？我让大家拉片了，是不是？
加勒比海盗的故事是。
一个叫什么？那叫。
官二代的千金呃，官二代那个女孩伊丽莎白，她她爹是反正类似于市长吧，咱们就暂且叫她。好吧，海边小镇那个市长。
和这个我们这个男主角铁小铁匠，但是这个小铁匠有一个隐藏身份，他是著名海盗之子。
两个人呢有。
有有情愫。
这个女的最起码很挚烈的爱着这个男孩，但是这个男孩呢因为自己身份低V，身份低微呀，他不他不敢呀，人家是什么身份，你是什么身份？所以他不敢，所以开场戏是什么？这个女孩喜欢这个男孩，然后就跟这个男孩去撒娇。你这个男孩到铁匠嘛？
到这个他们家的王府来送宝剑，给他爹做了把宝剑嘛，等于是来送货。
对吧送货上门，然后呢就送这儿，然后在这等着。然后这个这个女孩呢。
就在里面穿那个束胸，代表他被束缚的人生嘛，穿那种很紧的束胸束上之后喘不过气儿来嘛，差点晕过去。然后呢，穿上之后就跑出来啊，这个就是跟这个小男孩，就他俩像小时候一样，就跑过来跟他撒娇，明显的就是喜欢这个男孩。这个男孩呢。
不敢。
然后呢，当着人家女孩的父亲的面。
那个那个那个。
这个小姑娘就说你你别毕恭毕敬的，咱俩是好朋友，你叫我伊丽莎白就可以了呀。
对吧然后这我们这个这个这个男主角就不敢嘛，就说不行不行，对吧？你是叫他姓什么呢？死亡吗？啊说你s望小姐，我不可以，然后这个女的就很生气，人家的爹呢就带着这个女孩去见她心目中比较满意的那个女婿，就是那个江。
将军对吧？道貌岸然那种贵族将军带着一头假发那种。
然后呢，我们这个男主角就在人家走远了，才敢叫一声，再见伊丽莎白，把爱情塑造好。
然后呢。
激率事件是什么呢？
到了海边。
我们这个。
这个这个伊丽莎白因为生气，对吧？恨自己喜欢的男孩不争气，也不敢表白，连叫我名字都不敢。然后呢，我爹又来带带我见这个。哎呀，这个油油头粉面的这个贵族公子哥，对吧？一气之下呢，再加上穿的那个束胸太憋气了。
也两眼一黑。
掉海里。
这就是激励事件掉海里。
其他情节我就不说了，你们自己去拉。
然后最后这个女孩被海盗掳走，然后绑架。
这个我们的这个男主被迫上呃要上路去救回自己的。
姑娘，然后呢，因为他没有经验，所以就需要找一个搭档，就是我们的你们认为的男一，其实是男二的杰克船长陪他一起去。
杰克船长呢是想找黑珍珠号，他呢是想找自己的。
女神找爱情。
然后经历过生死考验以后。
过程咱都不讲了。
回到平凡中来。
从平凡中来到平凡中去，最后一个镜头是什么呢？把女孩救回来了，终于。
有情人终成眷属啦，两个人站在女孩当时从掉下去的那个悬崖边上，两个人抱在一块儿。
达成了爱情。
这就是典型的从平凡中来到平凡中去。如果开场的时候，伊丽莎白说，你叫我伊丽莎白就好了。然后你说好的，伊丽莎白，然后嘎一莎就亲上去，这个故事就没有了。
因为你折腾了半天，最后不也是就这样了吗？不一定是你们俩在一块儿就行了吗？
你开始你早干什么来着？
对不对？所以说从平凡中来到平凡中去。
都是这样大部分啊，然后再说一个。
哇，这节课说的有点多啊。
这边擦一下。
第几个了？
啊，管他第几个呢？反正对第4个啊，就是主角的。
选择。
主角啊，我们说在这个主角在这个自己的历程中，在这个故事中至少要有两次选择。同学们，这两次选择在什么位置呢？第一次是激励之后。
激励之后，也就是上路那里。
击毙之后，你不是要上路吗？
对吧上路能力。
需要做出选择。
需要做授选的。第二次呢是在。
那个。
那个那个那个叫什么叫蜕变的那。
因为蜕变之后，你就要开始直面那个最大的危险，要做出重大牺牲了呀，在那里要做出选择。啥意思啊？就是说你的主角啊你不能太顺，你至少在这两个地方要做选择。
就是说你得给他选择的机会。
他有机会说，我操算了吧，是吧？
我这太危险了。
有必要吗？就是他得有这个选择机会。
不能什么事儿都往推着他往前走。
主角至少要有两次选择的机会。如果你做的那个选择，你觉得不明显，那你就会让他退缩一下。
或者让他做一下依次动作，明白我意思吗？
记住这个是很多。
进阶选手。
都容易遗漏和忽略的问题。
所以说我这节课讲的是进阶问题，没有写过的同学，没有写过全本的同学，你就不要听了。你听了你也不知道我们在说什么。
好吧，这两个位置一定要做出选择。
要做出选择，这个不要漏。
退伍。
关于啊这里说到蜕变，关于蜕变的处理方式。
什么叫蜕变？
关于蜕变蜕变这里啊。
我们说我在课场好像提过好几次，我说哪儿得死，对吧？得死个人什么的，导致有些同学认为这是唯一的方法。
这是这是唯一的方法和路径。其实不是这样啊，何为蜕变蜕变本身啊蜕变本身其实不是说一定要死人。
蜕片这里其实是重生。
重生是一种。
对吧就是重回母体。
我们说重生一般是重回母体啊，母体重生嘛。
重回母体是一种，就是你走以前走过的路，只不过你是你有了新的思索。
这个秘籍在你。
25分钟的时候就有了。
就这本秘籍。
只不过你没看懂。
很多武侠片是这么做的。
就是你这个秘籍你早就有了，你当时没有悟透。
天龙八部早就给你了，你降龙十八掌，你早就有了。
对吧那个那个那个周星驰那个如来神掌，你早就有了这本小说，你没有参透。
但是在这里呢，重生就重回母体。你为什么会上路？是因为你有那本书，你现在重新回到那本书，这就叫重回母体，母胎重生，这是一种。
还有啊这种牺牲的蜕变也有，对吧？就是你们理解的那种死个人牺牲的蜕变。
也有。
还有一种蜕变脱俗。
还有一种蜕变的常用处理方式就是脱俗，就是让你的主角脱俗。
咱们有句老话叫灭人欲而存天命嘛。
就是这个道理。
你马上就要存天命了，所以你在这里要灭人欲。
懂吗？
为什么那些宗教人士啊那个什么他们会禁欲，对吧？欲为欲欲望是人人本身的东西，你要存天理，你就要灭人欲。
所以呢很多时候蜕变这里的处理方式用脱俗。
我给大家举个例子啊。
还是我们那个我不是药神，我不是药神。我们说药神里面蜕变是用了死人的。
对吧这个陈勇这个角色，徐峥这个角色，他在蜕变那里死人了的。
是死人了的对吧？那个那个那个那个传军那个角色和黄毛都死了嘛。
他也用了脱俗了。
因为他这些伙伴啊，他都用了一圈。
你们记不记得他还有一个女性伙伴？
那个在夜间跳舞的那个那个角色。
程勇这个角色。
是我们的男主角。
他有一场戏跟这个。
这个你你这个角色是跳钢管舞的，我记得夜店跳钢管舞的吧。
这两个角色在喝大酒，喝醉了之后去了女的家里。
做事就是要酒后要乱性一下的。
但是这一块没打成。
对吧。
你有没有想过为什么？
你有没想过这场戏合理不合理？
咱们喝过酒的同学啊。
咱们说句良心话。
一个卖壮阳药的。
一个。
跳三馆舞，两个人喝大了酒。
孤男寡女，干柴烈火都已经脱衣服。
比划起来。
竟然还能停下。
你信吗？
为什么这里要停下呢？
灭人欲。
因为你这是人的欲望。
灭掉。
徐峥马上就要成神了。
就你这里不灭掉他的人欲，你后面他成神就成不了。
你在这里连区区一炮，你都停不下，你后面怎么可能舍弃掉财富，豁出去自己的人身自由，宁愿要蹲大狱，也要去帮助那些完全跟你素妹平生的人呢。
你为什么会做那些事情？
就是凡人成仙的故事嘛。程勇从一个小市民成为一个。
神要神，凡人成神是这个片子的主题。
你后面都成神了，你在这里连人欲都灭不灭了，灭不了吗？
我们说灭人鱼而存千里，就是这个道理。
所以说啊。
关于蜕变这里啊。
有蛮多方法的。
不要局限于死人，而且你写这个这些现实题材的时候，你很难死人吗？你动不动就死人吗？
好吧。
咱们作为进阶选手啊作为进阶选手。
需要了解有各种各样。
不要举下来。
掉一个人。
然后。
第六。
关于伙伴。
我们说伙伴呢就是主角的伙伴呢。
主角的伙伴。
在行动员上。
跟主角是同一个大目标。
据说你俩的A故事是一样的。
伙伴如果有自己的故事，就是说伙伴如果不是一个纯纯的工具人啊，纯纯的工具人，那就跟着走就行了。伙伴如果有自己的事儿。
也就是说，他有自己的逼故史，那么伙伴的逼故史要与。
主行动线我们说主行动线就是。
南一的就是主角的A故事。
伙伴的A故事要跟。
主角的A故事。
同一个方向。
就你也去那个地方啊，我也去那个地方。
叫。
相符。
但是伙伴如果有自己的逼护室，自己的小目标。
那么这个小目标。
主伙伴的小目标。
要与主线。
相克。
大家记住。
伙伴的小目标要与主线相克。
也就是说，他如果要办自己那个私事儿。
要克制我们的主线。
否则就别有私事了。
没有用。
废弃。
好吧。
分析。
因为我说除了主角以外，谁都不配有事儿，有事儿就是跟主角的主线相符相生或者相克，只有这两种可能。
但是你作为伙伴。
你的主行动力已经与主线相生了，那么你的思维小目标就一定要与主线相克。
否则不要写。
废弃。
不要出现。
这种戏。
我们说。
嗯。
我不是药神里面。
除了陈勇以外，除了徐峥这个角色以外。
吕受义也好，黄毛也好，神父也好，那个脱衣舞舞女也好，他们自己的私人生活的事儿一件也没描写。
一件没描写，他们所有的事儿全都服务于程勇卖药这条主线，懂吗？
疯狂的外星人里面。
沈腾没有私生活。
他是黄渤的伙伴，他啥事儿都没有。
他没有自己的事儿，他就是服务黄渤。
跟外星人这是猴之间的战斗。
自己没有小目标。
如果有，比如说卖酒卖酒挣钱，那就要克制黄渤的主行动力。他想要卖酒的时候，哎，他把猴给偷了。
惹的事儿克制我们的主线。
明白吗？
所以说这个一定要注意，好吧，伙伴。
如果有小目标，你必须。
正面克制正刚我们的主线。
要么就别别说，没有意义。
但是再写这边吧，无所谓啊。
再讲一个呃问题，关于反败。
刚说完伙伴，我们来说一下反派，反派常见的几个问题，咱们的这个这个这个不管是同学也好，职业的编剧也好，常犯的几个问题。反派。
一、不具体。
2、没计划。三不压迫。
所以反派啊，我们提几个要求，第一，具体出来谁。
谁？
是不是？
具体出来。
最好是个具体的人。
具体的人就好对付。
呃好好处理，不是说主角好对付他，咱们好对付他，咱们编剧好对付他。
好处理。
不具体很难做好吗？尽量具体。
第二，没计划。
就你做一个反派，你连自己的行动计划都没有，你看人灭霸。
一步一步安排的明明白白。
所为反派一定要有计划。
你主角可以吊儿郎当的。
反派必须是优秀生啊，优秀生做事是有步骤，有套路，有计划。
你没有计划，你也就做不到第三点所谓的压迫。
丫头一步步紧逼呀，你的反派是步步紧逼过来的呀。
他有压迫力呀。
没有压迫力，那不就不好看了吗？
好吧，所以访派一定要注意这几点，要具体他要有计划，他要不补。
明白了吗？
然后说到反派这里。
然后把把这个也也也。
也讲了啊，就是关于这个。
讲道理的问题。
咱们的角色啊，咱们的同学有些作品里面很喜欢讲点道理。
很喜欢讲点道理。
哦。
我一般是不主张讲道理的。
为啥呢？因为。
道理不是那么好讲。
善恶议员呀。
就善恶其实说到底是一样的。
哪有那么多道理可讲？
但是你非要讲的话。
有些同学还是爱讲的，爱表达。
非要讲的话，我给大家。
定个规矩。
主角。
你给我讲小道理。
反派。
才能讲大道理。
主角讲小道理是什么意思啊？就主角的道理啊很小。
比如说主角的道理就是有仇必报。
他杀了我妈嘞。
我要报仇。
或者主角的道理是。
这个这个这个坚持就是胜利，对吧？或者主角的道理就是这个这个。
这个那个什么。
呃，滴水之恩当涌泉相报，这主角的道理啊往往是个小道理，他认死理。
然后呢，大道理啊留给对手讲。
关于人类，关于世界的平衡，对吧？关于宇宙的规矩，这大道理留给对手去讲。
你们先听我的。
回头你们自己遇到的时候慢慢去体会。
主角讲小道理，对手讲大道理。
但是我还是再强调一遍，我不主张大家讲太多的道理。
我虽然说过故事需要有主题，主题也很重要，而且主题必须是正能量。但是我也同时强调过啊，主题服务于人物和事件一个故事啊，最重要的是什么人办了一个什么事儿？
你是那个东西精彩吸引大家。
而不是你的主题精彩吸引大家。所以顺序一定要搞清楚，是先有人和事儿形成这个故事，把这个故事讲精彩的同时。
你在考虑。
他是不是有点主题？
甚至我说的极端一点。
你如果有一个好的故事，你暂时没有主题，那你也。
先写你先写主题会有的。
你不用刻意。
好，关于主题啊，就是主角讲小道理就可以了。对手可以讲大道理，但是主题真的没有那么重要，不要太。
就是说没有你想的那么重要，它很重要，但没有你想的那么重要，它次于人物和事界。
这是关于这个这个道理这一块啊，然后。
再说一个。
嗯。
长久。
场景这个问题。
在我这个月看过的基本上所有的剧本里。
都是短板。
很多同学啊在写剧本的时候，写全本的时候，往往只注重人物啊、对话呀、动作呀、环境场描述啊。
忽略了一个场景问题。
在这里我给大家提一下。
给大家规定一下。
咱们班的同学必须把场景当做一个元素来对待。
就说不要加办公室、车里、饭店、咖啡厅、咖啡厅，你们最己喜欢写一部一部戏，他妈有他妈十几场戏。
一共7场戏，有十几场在咖啡厅。
哪有那么多咖啡要喝啊，哪有那么多咖啡要喝，你只不过是想找个地方聊天而已。
对不对？
所以说。
对吧也不能在你家，不能在我家。然后呢，我跟你又不是一个单位，那咱俩在哪聊呢？又有咖啡厅，又有饭店。
场景不要过于单一，场景要作为一个元素。
来表达。
明白吗？
因为场景啊它也是可以传达信息的。
他也可以是。
有很重要的作用啊。
对你这个人物或者对事件来说啊。
那么简单说，你去找你的老板。
你未必要去他的办公室嘛？
你可以去高尔夫球场找他吧。
对不对？
他上班时间并没有在办公室，他在高尔夫球场呀，你可以去高尔夫球场找他呀。
那么这场戏是不是就比在办公室里要好看一些呢？而且这个场景是不是也传达了一些信息呢？
明白吗？你们自己去体会。
好吧。
把场景作为一个重要元素来对待。大家记着这句话，写完剧本之后检查一遍你的场景。
它是一个武器，就说你不要把它说哎呀，只要有个地儿就行了，它也是一个武器，你可以用的，别浪费了，是这个意思好吗？
然后第10个。
关于对话。
对话枯燥的问题。
依然存在。
对话枯燥，对话像流水账这个问题依然存在，很严重。
很多人都避免不了。
我在讲对白的那节课说过一些方法，对不对？我今天再给大家加一个加一个方法。
加一个方法。
如何解决你的对话？
枯燥。
对话没有意思的问题就是给。
给你的对话适当的增加势能。
适当的增加势能。
比如说。
一对夫妻。
在家里的一段对话，你本来是想用这段对话表达一些信息，推进一些剧情。但是呢你觉得很枯燥。
你觉得很枯燥。
那么你就可以考虑一下，我可不可以给他们两人之间增加一个势能呢？
比如说。
这个女的女方对男方有点小误会，有点生她的气了。
所以每一句话虽然还是那些内容，但是每一句话要枪他，要咄咄逼人。
要怪他。
是不是？
这个方法有很多的。
有很多的。
增加各种各样的势能，从情绪的角度，对吧？我生你的气了，或者是我想要点钱是吧？对话这还是些对话。但是呢我想讨好你。
要点钱想讨好，对吧？
这个这个。
还是这夫妻俩。
呃，这个女方要找男方。
这个这个这个。
来。
聊天对话，这些对话还是你的那些内容。但是呢。
这个女女女女主进来这个男男男主的房间的时候，男主正在。
看毛片儿。
咔就一一关，对吧？但是你这裤子还没提上去。
那你看对话还是这些对话，但是呢势能又有了，我要我作为男方，我要隐藏一个东西。
对吧。
那就不就又有势能了吗？而且又符合你的这个这个角色的人设。
明白这个意思吧？就是你的对话太干。
往往是因为。
这个对话的双方之间缺乏势能。
它是能量。
没有能量，你知道吧？没有能量，很容易干巴巴的，你一句我一句说相声。
这个大家去体会。
你先把对话写出来啊，当然我还是说这句话，咱们这堂课你得这堂课的内容，你得先有剧本。
才能聊啊，你得先真的写过东西才能聊。你先得有对话，我们才能改善这个对话的势能。
明白这个意思吧？
我今天就讲这么多吧，好吧，等遇到别的问题的时候，再详细跟大家讲。因为最近呢确实是一直在看项目，看剧本，然后。
呃，送去备案，咱们这个。
咱们国家这个剧本备案呢要要半年呢是吧？要要审半年。所以最近在教很多项目，半年之后听结果看哪个项目。
通过了审查。
所以最近看剧本非常多。
然后发现共性的问题呢，值得探讨的问题，我也会及时跟大家一起分享。
达到咱们这个实战课的目的。
但是还是。
希望大家多写多练，否则我光跟你说这些问题，你心里觉得啊，到时候不会出这些问题的，你记不住那么多呀，你不写，你怎么知道哪些问题是你会遇到？
好吧，大家可以根据。
嗯，我在。
有一课里面我教过大家怎么写一个策划案，先根据那个格式那个思路自己去策划一些项目。
然后呢，这呃我准备下阶段呢在咱们的班级里啊。
或者先从七班，咱们实验实验班。
这个先试点。
给大家搞一些。
命题类的一些。
提案征集，然后希望给大家也是。
尽快的。
搞一些能够上线的作品。
写了好的同学。
就是尽快的。
转成职业化。
尽快的这个有自己的作品。
希望吧，好吧。
这节课就上到这了。
下课。